[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone persia here and welcome
to a very special episode
of gamespot live today's stream is
sponsored by marvel future
revolution and it's the very first open
world action rpg on moba and i'm really
excited to be checking out this game but
of course
i cannot do it alone we'll be joined by
some
amazing guests starting with marvel
super fan greg miller from kind of funny
games how's it going greg
it's great persia how are you i am good
so glad to have you we're also joined by
danny kuh
director of product development at
marvel games how's it going danny
hi appreciate doing well here hope
you're doing well too
i am thank you so much and we're also
joined by joe
lee the production director from net
marble how's it going joe
hey persia excited to be here me
too and all of us are going to be
checking out some amazing stuff today
and we're obviously teaming up with
martial
marvel future revolution to present
various
things about the game whether it be the
story the open world
the customization options the skill sets
and
even more like two really awesome
multiplayer mode splits and special
operations
whew all right i'm so excited to get
started but i
have to know a little bit more about
what's on the way like some
very exclusive codes and news right joe
yeah so we're dropping huge news at the
end of the stream
as well as dropping a code like you just
mentioned for some cool in-game
collectibles
so stick around to the end of the stream
so you make sure you see it
definitely stick around and for everyone
tuning in
a new future begins because marvel
future revolution
is marvel's very first open world action
rpg
on mobile and we've got a nifty little
video so you can check it out
[Music]
marvel future revolution
that's right that's right an amazing
starter here
greg you look like you got some
questions up your sleeve what's going on
i i have a million questions up my
sleeve uh yeah for me
uh with this game right like i had been
on one of our podcasts over kind of
funny and i had mentioned when
they started pitching spider-man games
what would a multi-player spider-man
game
be like and i pitched out that it'd be
like oh we'd all be able to come
together
you'd be able to customize your own
spider-man customize your own powers
that would be your spider-man that would
be it
and once i said that on a podcast i got
a comment from one of our viewers that
was like yeah that sounds really great
greg
i don't know if you know that's just
marvel future revolution and i was like
oh
really and that's when i went to look in
so danny
you're over at marvel where does this
start from how do you guys decide this
is the kind of game you want to do or
does it start with joe where does the
actual idea for marvel future revolution
come from
oh so um uh this other title on marvel
future fight it was a great success for
both marvel and net marble
um the game has been over six years and
the the both the game
and the community are aging pretty well
uh this success has actually inspired us
to do more
something great something revolutionary
so
after a few years of working hand in
hand with our friends at marvel like
danny
we bring you the result which is of
course marvel future revolution
several several years ago like i i know
joe like forever
it's been like i know six years over six
years that we've known each other
a few years back the games industry yeah
a few years ago we met together and we
we kind of want to do the next big thing
after a marvel future fight what's what
what's the next big thing so we
discussed and we decided that you know
open world would be
uh good on mobile that's the next big
thing back then
the technology has not caught up yet but
thank god
the technology has caught up with us and
and here we are today
introduce marvel's first open action rpg
on mobile for everyone
exactly for everyone which
if you want to pre-register you can do
it right now over at
marvelfuturerevolution.com to be ready
for launch day
and receive a comics inspired in-game
costume for a hero of your choice
so definitely stick around for that it's
going to be awesome
and we are now going to hop into the
meat and potatoes of the stream
quick overview in case you missed it
earlier we are discussing a ton of
things about
the story the new universe the open
world
that was developed by marvel comics with
mark zumarak and marvel games
we are also taking a deep look into
character customization
and also the skill sets and we are
checking out two multiplayer modes later
with another very special guest blitz
and special operations
so i'm super excited to go ahead and hop
on in
but before we do i gotta send the
question around the table really quick
starting with greg
what are you excited to see today the
most
oh for me it's seeing you know what
costumes are going to be there like you
know how
how into the weeds can we get to
customize our captain america our
spider-man our captain marvel
and what about you joe i would like to
see the uh the level of freedom that we
provide with the game
since we actually have multiple layers
of customization like like drake just
said but
on top of just the costumes we also have
like masteries
skills and stuff like that awesome
and danny what you looking forward to
today oh i'm
i'm just excited to watch the the show
unfold itself like see how
how how players play together right now
this this game
is meant to play together for everybody
so let's see how it works out
all right i'm looking forward to it too
honestly
all this talk has been fantastic but now
i am actually going to hop
into the game run around and you know
pass the rings off to greg a little bit
while i have some fun
yeah the interview reigns if you notice
ladies and gentlemen i'm not allowed to
play i'm not allowed to have a leveled
up 100 iron man out there ready to do
anything
not that i'm jealous not that i'm
jealous of your black and gold very
clearly mizzou inspired iron man but
yeah i love it this is actually the
marvel now costume
pre-register you guys so you can look as
fresh
as i do right now all right sorry greg
all you it's done
oh no don't please don't worry about it
all right we're definitely
turning back and seeing what you're up
to right so joe one of the things as
uh persia hops in here for select a hero
you see the iron man logo lit up and
then you see the three pluses beneath it
and then some locks
how does this work is it that we have
four characters on our roster that we're
able to choose and then play through
your s
yeah you're right um we actually provide
eight eight playable characters at
launch
so you actually have the freedom to
choose uh like who
whichever character that you want to
play with and then if you actually want
to you know go for even more than before
that is actually given then you actually
have the you know
the choice to actually you know go ahead
and free those
uh frito slots too sure of course
and so then as we now just pan around
this world map
people are looking at this maybe they've
never seen this game they noticed this
is not
earth as we know it we see hydra empire
we see new stark city omega flight
headquarters what exactly is going on
in the story here danny so
this this the story set up is multiple
reality converge into each other
uh a group of superheroes uh you know
with omega flight
uh try to stop the convergence of this
multiple reality from
happening unfortunately you know despite
all their efforts
there's nothing they can do about it and
a large ditch effort
by the great vision sacrifice himself to
ensure that all this reality
merge together in this new primary earth
and everyone co-exists with each other
and of course with this
new region uh you know super villains
from each of this new reality
try to take over this place and you know
take advantage of this situation
you as a player being recruited to join
the
superhero squad or make a flight to
ensure that you know
all this evil doesn't happen and also
prevent future convergence
from happening for sure and i think
that's you know for me as a
comic book fan as an mcu fan right i
love
the way you guys are already blending
the worlds together so like you know i
got to play a little bit of it and it
was you know
you're i'm spider-man i'm running around
you're choosing what shows of course
spidey is one of my playable characters
i'm running around as him and right
another spider-man shows up in his base
like hey this is what's happening you
need to come with us we need to go you
know save the
multiverse and you get to pop in there
and immediately have that set up and see
it and see how it unfolds and see
tony stark talking over new stark city
in the avengers tower mixed out there
and all these different easter eggs
you talked about the writer mark what
reigns did you give for writing this
story for creating the story for talking
about the conversions was it just
whatever they wanted to go make
so like the you know like how we work at
marvel games with
all creators in this case net marble we
give them the freedom
uh to pick and choose you know iconic
marvel references characters locations
you know
to channel the great bill roseman from
our creative
team he once said you know think of a
game like a
pizza right net marble you are the chef
there are tons of ingredients you know
pineapple
bacon you know pepperoni oh
you know take these patches of
ingredients and put them all together
and you know make the your own version
of the pizza
right in this case uh you know we work
with mark zumarek
the writer when that mother come up with
this unique story
uh epic adventure and and able to
present to the players all new and
exciting refresh you might be familiar
with uh you know certain marvel
references
if you're a avid comic reader or you
even if you're a moviegoer
and you watch a marvel cinematic
universe movie
um there are so many uh little little
stuff that get put together in this game
it's amazing and of course we're not
going to stop here we're going to
continue expand this universe
to make it bigger and bigger because
this is
an open world and you need a great story
to support it
well that's the thing right you talk
about joe your team at denmark will be
able to do whatever you want go through
this right
and here we are on it looked like xander
earth xande earth right shoving together
xandar and earth into one place on it
you're fighting a sentinel
there's a bunch of stuff in the
background i know i'm already catching
as easter eggs like
what was that like joe because it sounds
number one like oh what an amazing thing
i can go create whatever i want but then
i have to
have to imagine there's that oh my god i
can go create whatever i want like what
are we gonna do with this
well as being the chef doing this for
the pizza right i mean
we actually decided to um like throw
what kind of topping that we wanted
to throw on like it could be kimchi it
could it could be bulgogi
whatever but then you know like when it
comes to the game
then we actually you know like like
danny like mentioned earlier
all right now the game is ready for some
mobile you know legitimate open world
game then we would be like let's
let's throw some all right some real
time stuff on there let's throw some
like more challenging stuff on there
and while at the same time we wanted the
game to be a welcoming experience so
this actually is like a gift from one
fanboy and
fan girl group to the rest for the
marvel fans right
like we wanted to make sure that we have
something for everyone
like zanderth right there i mean we
actually um
maybe some of you already might have
noticed that there was actually
sanctuary
the mothership right there on the screen
yeah that's actually the mothership of
thanos and stuff like that that you
could familiarize with right
that you the knowledge that you have
from the mcu the comics and all that so
it's going to be like oh wow i know that
oh wow i feel right at home being a
marvel fan and all that kind of well
yeah right there
is that nowhere back there is that also
nowhere no that's the moon
that's actually the uh no where moon
that we set up on there
yeah stuff like that i mean you know we
wanted this game to be
all right for both not just the marvel
fans being hardcore from like just
that just lived and breathed marvel
comics from the beginning
or it could be from like some you know
newcomers to the to the ip as well and
also for
the game itself so for sure
oh yeah i think it works right because
that's the you know again whenever bill
roseman
talks about marvel games right he's
talking about this idea that
marvel is something different to
everyone and there is something for
everyone and so i think having those mcu
references but also then i know
you have so many different comics
inspired outfits in your comic related
pieces
like you're building a game really that
is approachable i think for anything
exactly so if this is your first time
coming in
to this game or this ip
you know even if you start from scratch
uh you will feel
right at home um will take care every
step of the way to explain the situation
of the world the relationship between
each characters you know and you're
gonna have a fun
have a good time in this game so joe one
of the things is you know we jumped
right in here we wanted to show gameplay
of course gameplay is king people want
to be able to see what they're going to
be playing on their mobile
devices here there is of course a story
we've talked about i wanted to call out
the fact you've seen it in so many cut
scenes even from a little bit i've done
i've thought the cut scenes in the story
presentation is so
well done it is tony stark talking to me
right it is bla
being a black widow's side it is rolling
into battle with captain marvel and
really feeling that cinematic nature of
it
right now as persia flies around and as
iron man what is happening not so much
in the story but what is she doing what
is the goal of what she's up to right
now
well basically this is the proper um mmo
or open world experience that we wanted
to provide with the game right
i mean if you actually want to want to
play like a you know superhero game
if it is a marvel game then you want to
be able to fly around like
what she's doing right now in the screen
and if you want to be and
also you want to have some larger than
life action combos and stuff you know so
make sure that you're actually you know
giving the bad guys what they deserve
and stuff like that so and all of this
we wanted to make sure that everything
is just running in real time
right it's not just going to be you like
what we're seeing on the screen but
when the game is out when when it's
actually in the real
server environment it's going to be
filled with you know lots and lots more
people
you know playing together and you know
that was basically what we wanted
you know like um to give with the game
sure yeah and i think you know right now
oh please go ahead danny oh as i say
it's possible that you run across
some other spidey it's like oh look
that color is actually quite cool so you
know take a selfie with them if you want
which which is great pretty great let's
kind of show off your costume to other
players as well
oh man no that's the most exciting thing
about it today i popped i was playing
and i popped the uh scarlet spider
uh jumpsuit top in pink and i was like
oh yeah
like that i want to see what other
people are doing with their spider-man i
want to see what other people are doing
to captain marvel
you know uh persia i know you're talking
about it earlier like you know right now
you're running around basically just
grinding out like you're talking about
joe and any action rpg mmo right
but it's that idea you're gonna play
later and so that's what
i'm excited about right is that ability
of okay cool i have 15 minutes here 10
minutes there in between things go in
run these open areas grind out whatever
the dailies are and then have those
moments where i text my friends like
okay cool i want to go do blitz okay i
want to go get this daily reward that we
need to group up for
can we get in there and do it together
and i think that's such an interesting
way i do have a
question from the chat over on twitch.tv
slash gamespot uh mecha robot says
is this a free-to-play mobile game he's
new he hasn't heard of it yet but he
thinks it looks cool
oh well it's not it's you know it's a
great time to catch up with the rest of
the world now
it is free to play and it is on mobile
so
all that you're seeing um well we try to
call it a
aaa quality graphics on a smaller screen
you know it's going to be free for you
to download and then all of the you know
like
beautiful contents we created you could
just play with
whoever you want to make you know like
party up with and all that stuff
soon when the game launches and make new
friends
and make this chat has a bet you know if
i can get a release date out of you guys
so i'm going to keep leaning on you
anytime you want to tell us the release
date that would be great one of them is
promising me a free video game if i can
get it so i would like that personally
not to mention i just want to play
well let me slide in with the smoothest
of segways you mentioned some
character customization earlier and i
think it's time to check it out but
also for anyone who is just now tuning
in
today's stream is sponsored by marvel
future revolution
and players can pre-register right now
at marvelfuturerevolution.com to be
ready for launch
and to receive a comics inspired in-game
costume
for a hero of your choice that's pretty
awesome so make sure you stay tuned
to the end for that so back to the
customization
there are literally millions and
millions of different character
customization options we have this fully
kitted iron man here that we're gonna
get to check out very exciting
um but yeah i mentioned it earlier this
very
clean and fresh costume we got here on
iron man
is what you're going to get if you
pre-reg so the marvel now costume is
looking so good
make sure that you check that out but
let's check out some more of this stuff
whoa all right every time i see it and
it pops up
i'm always taken aback for a moment
[Laughter]
well yeah this is what we're talking
about right the options to go through
and yeah you know for everybody joining
you see over there
on the right side right head body arms
legs those are the four pieces you can
go in somewhere
you know when purge is talking about
millions she's talking about millions of
combinations where it is you know
you just saw the classic shell head iron
man right like first appearance one get
back but
oh my god a hot rod body right here
right like this is the stuff that makes
me mark out like i
i'm gonna enjoy playing through the game
and doing all the different stuff right
uh you know
uh danny you've talked before about how
mark worked on ultimate alliance three
right and how how much i loved
ultimate alliance three but to get into
the nitty gritty have that kind of
gameplay that action rpg feel to it
and then be able to go through and put
on this kind of helmet with this kind of
body like
yes please yeah they're exciting that's
a in fact that's
over 400 million uh combination per hero
so wow have fun at it and we're good
we're not going to stop there
matt marvel has created different kind
of costumes in there
you know costume inspired by the comics
costume inspired by the
cinematic universe and also original
costumes are inspired by the various
regions
found in this game as well
and so that's an interesting piece so
like obviously again we get it persia
has a fully leveled out character she's
the chosen one for the stream i get it
but when i get to start this up on
launch day and i start playing through
uh joe how am i unlocking different
outfits you talked about them being in
different areas
is it that way is it is it mission
rewards is it daily things like
how am i getting all these pieces how am
i acquiring gear
um we're trying to be pretty generous
about how much
we're giving away by you know giving as
rewards by completing quests where it
could be
like some daily rewards login rewards
and also like there are going to be
events
that actually give provides you with
your costume rewards and
also omega cards and some of the other
you know like
growth factors from the game and there
will be some other ways to actually you
know like
to to to go get ahead
from everybody else by maybe being a
little bit competitive
being more a little bit more competitive
and some other ways too
persia your iron man is getting dark
this is
a scary iron man at this i
am living right now these are
so dope and being able to mix together
the combinations
like the helmet and the chest piece are
not from the same place
that they look so good together i'm
i'm thoroughly enjoying myself right now
joe what's your favorite costume in this
um i would say all right you don't have
any piece of that
on you know wearing at the moment but my
my
mine would be the new start city one
that was actually one of our first takes
on
you know creating our original versions
for the costumes
and you know when you're actually
creating a game and developing a game
for like
years to come and then there has to be
some magic moments like
wow this is going to be great and i
think that was actually first
one one of the first magic moments that
actually you know that like
surprised the song that this could just
work
sure yeah right there so now
but i like it this is another thing i
like so parts you can go through and do
one by one but as
perch is showing right now you can go in
and do themes and so they already have
them pre-built right that's the idea
that hey here is this
suit that matches you can quick equip it
and get back out there
yeah i'll tell you my favorite yeah my
my favorite is
savage shadow land you know because uh
you know it's a combination of uh you
know savage land and
shadow land you know uh you know how
does
the ninja defense against monster right
if you look at this
it looks super epic
it's so cool like i think he has some
other colors that
you can put on as well
i actually love that you can kind of see
a little bit of his arm
through the through it so although he
looks like he is definitely
some demon-esque like entity it's
totally tony's dark under there
i love it yeah so on top of all the
decorative um
purposes for making your um superhero
look unique and to your taste
and there are some you know like
gameplay benefits too like some of the
perks
that unlocks by um you know equipping
the same uh same gears from the same set
and stuff like that and
that actually only motivates you to
actually you know stick around with the
game as long as possible
and being as competitive as possible as
well so that's actually one of the you
know factors that we
wanted to make sure that it is you know
like
motivating enough well sure i have to
imagine that it's got to be recorded
fear itself nice yeah that's the fear
itself i mean
um that's actually one of my personal
favorite as a fan of marvel
back in my future fight days i mean you
know like um you know we all
me and danny we always talk back and
forth about all right for what's going
to be the next for our update what's
going to be the next for our updates and
if yourself was one of the biggest
candidates we always had in mind because
you know like um if you actually look at
the story
of the comic books then you know if they
like the whole team
and pretty much everybody has the set of
you know uru power gears right
and i always thought it was going to be
you know like a great fit for gay
material
and now we finally have it for future
revolutions
all right well i mean they're all
stunning even mixing them together so i
mean you choose different color
palettes and you know all these
different regions you can get them from
definitely looking forward to more but
now i think it's time
you know we've done a lot of
customization but let's check out some
skills and of course to do that we had
to bring in another very special guest
i'd like to bucketman cynic alex to the
show
alex how are you how's it going we are
gonna
kick some butt today and uh yeah welcome
hey persia super excited to be here
thrilled and i want a piece of that
pizza
so i'm gonna be doing my best
what's your favorite girl hungry
canadian bacon
pineapple oh oh wow
this man chose violence this morning
exactly um all right so
i know that seeing all of these skills
maybe at first glance can be a little
overwhelming
but break it down for all of our viewers
alex let them know
what exactly they can expect when
they're picking up the game
so when you first start in the game like
if you're greg and you haven't even
played the game for
real launch yet you know he's gonna have
to start at level one he's not gonna be
level 100 like us
you're not gonna be bombarded with all
of iron man skills he's got a lot of
skills and they're very cool
but you're just going to start with a
few and then as you level you're going
to unlock
more and then as you level even further
you will unlock these really cool
skill masteries that are going to change
the skills in extremely unique ways
and joe can you give us a little more
insight on specialization
before we uh talk more about these
specific skills
because that's important too right all
right that's actually specialization
you're still
looking at right there um you are
actually able to build up
your own specialization build with the
rewards that actually
come in kind of later in the game with
the mode called
the rates so once you're actually done
with choosing like which um
skills and which um masteries that you
actually want to build up this is
actually one of the
later stuff that you actually get to
face with and this is where you actually
truly feel to be
the superhero that you want to be right
so actually by building up to a certain
direction
of the specialization then that actually
allows you to be
like to a certain type let's say like a
trial control heavy
or it could be uh dps efficiency heavy
or it could be like aoe heavy like
whatever play style that you want to be
or it could be
like if you want to be just great at pvp
then you can actually choose to you know
build up to which direction and stuff
like that
how about all of them all of them you
could make
you could actually do that too it just
would you know like
you know take a little longer alex is up
for the challenge alex is ready to throw
it all away and devote his life
i'm ready coach put me in all righty
all right sounds good i mean i know
there were even more skills i have some
different skills equipped
than alex has for my iron man um
and yeah there is definitely a lot uh
danny what are some of your favorite
skills for iron man
oh definitely party protocol oh i think
alex has that one
let me see it alex nice choice great
choice
what about what are you doing yeah why
alex why is party protocol great
it's really cool because it's not only
going to do damage for you but then it's
going to call down
to other iron man suits and we've seen
iron man use
and you guys have been showing fear
itself all these different looks for
iron man
it's going to call down to other iron
man that will actually and sometimes
look different than your iron man as you
can see we've got the darker iron man's
to complement the red
and they're gonna all help you take some
you know pressure off of you with some
you know targeting but also deal damage
to your enemies whether it's in pve
or pvp that's right um
this game is actually meant to be played
with other friends and stuff right so
there are some specialization builds and
you know like steel mastery trees
that is actually for the maximum
efficiency when it comes to the party
play
like for the synergized effect with your
friends and stuff
so we're about to see
oh we're about to see you say
well i think i know what that means yeah
so
what we're seeing on the screen that's
your your uh that's persia setting right
so that was actually meant to be like
the sustainable combat setting
that actually utilizes a special
specialization build with some stamina
recovery and
decrease bonus you know paired with some
of the skills that do not require too
much stamina
and cooldown so allowing purges iron man
to be
going on and on with the highest um dps
efficiency
so that was paid persia right there
while on the other hand cynic alex's
on skill tree might be something else
right what do you have
alex oh there you guys kidding me out
with some really good stuff here we got
a lot of aoe damage incendiary bomb
laser cutter cutter danny's favorite
party time protocol
napalm bomb i'm here to just take that
crowd control after
purchase stunned all the mobs or bombed
them or snared them
and just bombard them with a lot of
tony's signature
missile moves yeah that's the whole
point for his build which is actually
supposed to be
the crowd control or it could be like
the party part
the favorite guard in favor guy in the
party
kind of a you know setting like that
actually you know it gives you some more
you know like perks and bonuses on like
synergize effects
and like some um improved and increased
um debuff duration as all of that stuff
so i mean you know
we'll see which one works better and all
that stuff
depending on your choice all teamwork
if you're playing together in a way
all this chat about playing i have the
itch to play now
so i think it's time to hop on over to
check out some of these multiplayer
settings alex and i are gonna team up
we've also got some friends who are
gonna team up with us
on the back end and we're gonna check
out first
the blitz mode so we're gonna head over
to these operations
and the blitz let's uh let's kick it up
a notch
shall we let's try never
ending winter all right i have
i've started it i believe hopefully
you guys are ready
to see all those videos there are so
many villains yeah exactly people coming
in
the thing is the night
connection out here yeah we are really
canon
[Applause]
so joe this is such a crash course for
people who are like me i think that have
been interested in seeing the trailers
but like are finally seeing the game and
learning what it is
what is blitz and why would i play blitz
as a player
bliss is actually like a boss fight
stage mode that actually lets you farm
some of the you know some of the gears
like what we call battle badges
so that so this is supposed to be
playing you played by
you know played a solo work with your
friends as well so if you think you're
you know good enough
to take on the boss by yourself you know
go take me take your stab at it
or if it is something like lafayette who
is actually being pretty notorious for
you know like being pretty difficult
then you might be ready
stuff like that okay so coming in yeah
can you explain can you
explain to me what a battle badge is i'd
seen it when we went to the equipment
screen right before we went in and put
you know the costume stuff was up in the
top right but then you had
battle badges down here in the lower
right what is a battle badge
battle badge is like when you talk like
from the conventional rpgs it could be
like equipment
that actually gives you you know like um
improved stats and damages and also it
could be the
increased hp or like all of that stuff
sometimes it could be like critical
rates and all that you know like beauty
stuff
okay so you're gonna need like stronger
battle badges
if you actually want to you know grow up
strong enough to face anybody like lao
faye right there
hersh he looks intimidating what's your
confidence level right now
[Laughter]
you know what we've got the team
we're looking good we're feeling good i
learned how to use my dodge button
that's very important i think we're good
here let me go help alex actually
thank you don't worry alex i got you
thank you bring that jarvis in yes yo my
satellite though i get three of them
just raining down damage from the
heavens
there you go yes apply that defense down
let's go
now you found the dodge button that's
good did you find the lock on button
persia
oh nice i did i'm using it
you know i had pro training from the
mobile game
master himself alex
another alex is a multiverse let's go
i think she means you she's talking
about baltimore
multiple danny in instances all over the
digital world multiple copies of
ourselves
yeah what a lame game you can get in
you can have played right you can play
any version of a marvel here you get in
it's any version of
the youtube influencers it's me and alex
like all right change their share
all right now greg plays xbox games
all right i think you guys are doing
good
first is showcasing all the skills laffy
can use against you
yes you know grab by that ice watch out
watch out
i let iron man get frozen this is my
favorite
oh nice satellite they're almost there
oh wait hold on
almost there yeah watch out for those
warning signs yeah yeah gotta see a man
about a dog
ah okay we're good it's also that's your
patient as well
persia confidence level right now but
i'm feeling good i'm feeling versus hp
level right now
oh you know he heard me talking and he
said you sure about that
no okay we're gentle less than one bar
to go
we got this let's see if i oh no i'm
right in the cusp
no no we lost captain marvel
no we gotta do that we gotta do it for
carol
listen i like you both but i don't know
i don't know if you got the stuff
you know no we got it we got this oh
we got them on the ropes yeah yeah
that's guardian ropes the
heim ropes
on the rainbow bridge nice we need
heimdall
just a little more dodge
you're doing pretty well persia is an
expert now
i know all those guys are training
he's so dead oh my goodness okay maybe
not
oh there we go party protocol hey all
right
you know the combos you know feeling
good feeling good
that's awesome okay that's not the only
multiplayer mode that we're checking out
today though
that was just blitz we're also gonna
check out
special operations which
ups the stakes a little bit danny do you
want to tell us
about special operations and uh maybe
shed some tips because my confidence is
dwindling a little bit
after that last fight so
uh you know special operations like a
special mode uh
for you to team up with your friends to
live you know the lives of superheroes
in the game you know it can be you know
defending against a wave of enemies
over a location or it can be survival
inside
an arena or you know you can rescue
civilians
um and and and rack up points with each
other
so yeah hopefully hopefully through this
you can kind of figure out who who who
is your
real true teammates
yeah on top of what danny just mentioned
on specialization
i mean special operation is meant to be
a fair mode
what we do with this mode is we actually
balance everybody's um
level to be maxed up at 100. so it
doesn't matter
how geared you are or how uh how how
you know equipped you are right it's all
about your skills and it's
all about your expertise about the level
design and the patterns
of the of the content so you can see
who is the teamwork expertise and who
could be the damage dealing
expertise and all that stuff and also
who carries
who require carries sure sure
i'm gonna need it alex i will require
carries when the time comes when this
game is officially out momentum
greg level one greg chopping it up
really dodging really really getting out
there showing them what's up
all right joe i'm putting you to the
test right now we want to head over to
the sakaar arena so would i have to head
back to hq to activate that or
do we get there
i believe we can go back to the hq right
joe
i think you might want to cancel the
query that you put in
and then choose it back
all right go back to special operation
start matching
it's going to be xander's defense
oh he's jumping on persia that's the
mission for the day
all right sounds good making sure i was
on the right one i didn't want to get
left behind without alex i would have
been really terrified
we got this double iron man can't lose
all right we are in we are in a 10
minute time limit
who could it be uh-oh
where was that where would it have come
in earth that's sanctuary
that century
they are here the sixth century okay
we got we got bogies on the right and
bogus on the left
yep yep copy that
so wave after wave after wave make sure
you actually um
defend the convergence engine right
there oh yeah
yeah that's the whole goal
whoa look at those points up there
serotonin on these number levels i'm not
gonna lie
yup
alex this is where you come in because
you have the you know
crowd control stuff all set up for your
bill
set him up persia knocks him down
here we go yes all that aoe
oh we got one straggler
there we go nice over there he's uh
enjoying the view
let's go get them no loitering we can
pick up these uh buffs as well
red blue and yellow buffs now we got
this what are they
when you're picking these up like how do
you then use them do you want to pick up
red to fight a certain enemy alex or is
it
leave them all for me greg just leave
them all for me uh no
so the red ones are gonna buff your
attack
you can actually see that under the
stamina bar oh i yeah under the stamina
bar the yellow stamina i got a little
sword for my attack
got blue ones if you get hurt i'm gonna
heal you
and then the yellow ones are gonna
increase your ultimate gauge and in iron
man's case
that is the ultimate unibeam
unibeam hell yeah
and that's obviously what's it for
people who are seeing the game for the
first time is what's filling in right
obviously you see the arc reactor on
your screen
slowly filling in with the white dots
around it that'll allow you to you know
be invented
now alex of course uh you're no stranger
to this game
you have a youtube channel that's just
chock full of marvel future revolution
videos
you have this dedication to a game
that's not out yet
what are your findings so far with it
like what is what is drawn
in the small country of canada no it's a
sophomore actually
all right okay i see everyone over i see
them on twitch.tv
spot right now i'm being like hey they
changed this they did this it's like
guess what
that's what happens when you're in the
beta and you're in the beta for america
yeah so when it gets to america that'll
be the time
we get mad about everything that's when
we're mad about decisions and they did
stuff because you're not in the beta
anymore
but my question alex is what are you
finding with it like why
are you drawn to play this game so much
man
there's just so much there's so much
this game it's in soft launch like you
said but it feels like it's
it feels like it's so familiar it's
something i've wanted to play and had
the imagination to play but not
the tech specs or the actual app to play
on any device
let alone on my phone for years you know
we've all dreamed of
you know jumping into this open world
and i'm spider-man you're spider-man i'm
captain america you're captain marvel
and now it's here and i love marvel and
i just love this kind of game to begin
with so it's just the marriage of these
two
amazing things more than two way more
than two but yeah
it's just it's the perfect pizza
hearing that from alex it's just melting
my heart
yeah i'm i'm with you alex right of like
the idea of being able to jump into this
sandbox this toy box right make your own
hero and then go out and
do i want to spend hours playing in the
day or do i want to spend 30 minutes
with it do i want to do the daily do i
want to chase this do i just
have something to do whether it is that
i'm just killing time in between calls
or something or you're actually getting
in there and have a new marvel story for
it right
it it smacks so much i'm right there
with you of what drew me to marvel
ultimate alliance three
and what i dug so much about that danny
uh and so then to have that here on a
mobile device and have that same kind of
experience ready to go
i'm stoked for it yeah let's bring it to
america dude
yeah let's go release team up then we go
so joe like what is so special ops the
big hook here is the time limit is that
the the fact that they rotate every day
to give you something new to do
yeah well every day we actually give you
a different mode like um there are
numerous different kinds of a variety
in terms of what what you can do like
what you're seeing right there that's
actually called obsidian that's um
um thanos is you know the hunchband
right oh we know so
so stuff like this kind of a defense
mode we have that
you know this is you know like um
surviving through wave after wave
but then there are other modes that
actually gives you you know like uh your
that test your skills to survive from
like the car arena
and also hydra empire stuff that
actually gives you
what it feels like to be rescuing
civilians
stuff like that like all kinds of
variety what it means to be like a
superhero and
we wanted this to be you know like once
again to be fair for everybody
make sure that you know like there's you
know something for you to do
you to play even though when you don't
think you're really ready or fully
geared up
worry not because we have the special
operation operation for you
and i'm looking for persia oh no
originally knocking it out i was like
you know over there beating somebody you
pay attention to the uh
to the engine yeah yeah conversion is
actually your job is to actually defend
that
not just call of duty he he's going to
get to us
you can leave him for now he'll find you
eventually don't worry about it right
right right right
yeah stick together right there okay
here we go
uh-huh all right there you go
hammer them let's go let's go
ow i am hurting excellent
i mean and you're healed up yeah
i mean alex got to be the savior of the
stream
can't just be a team player got to
remind everybody how good he is
no way no way
i'm embodying tony stark
oh crap well there i go that's true
you're really role-playing you're really
getting into it
oh
so joe obviously i will remind you that
there isn't a release date
uh and i would really like that at some
point but
while i wait for you to finally just
tell me uh what are you learning right
now you have the game is in soft launch
in a couple different territories right
like what are you guys learning right
now oh
what alex wait so joe hold on a second
with my question
alex what happened buddy you were so
confident
i was trying to help persia they swarmed
me
what don't over here on your youtube
channel
i don't want to hear so many videos
there's so many subscribers but you
still died playing the game
alex is still number two
yeah captain marvel's crushing it
higher further faster right right
exactly but joe back to you uh what are
you what are you guys learning right now
what are you taking away from
people actually getting their hands on
the game finally how how invaluable is
that how valuable is the feedback you're
getting on discord
uh discord twitter um yeah i mean um we
actually
wanted to have the you know like the
first and foremost idea about the the
genre how it would be you know like um
would be user friendly as much as
possible because if you're actually
playing any any kind of this kind of a
complicated rpg
um you want to stay away from you know
making the uh
learning curve too stiff or sure just
make the game too challenging
or stuff like that because you know when
you're making when you're actually
building a
game based on marvel that means you're
gonna have
all these you know like non-gamers that
probably didn't have
too much gaming experience previously in
their life right
sure though i mean like all of these you
know like stuff to learn and all these
information that needs to be
you know like um exposed and to be
familiar familiar
rise with yeah well it's actually
working out pretty well
i mean people are catching up we're
actually seeing a lot of you know like
um
the max level characters max level
players already
they just know how to you know get the
grip and just go
all that stuff yes we just got the grip
just like you said joe
yeah just like these guys right there i
mean
captain marvel so yeah we also
live mitchell a lot of requests coming
up from
from from uh from from the soft launch
you know we have eight playable
character roster they're like you know
where's hulk where's gene craig like
people would want to play as their
favorite marvel characters and we we
know that
we are collecting all this feedback and
and just want
to let everyone know we hear you and you
know we might have surprised in the
future so
stay tuned on that
yes of course definitely stay tuned and
jesus alex we did it
you know i i was a little scared at
first but
we handled that with ease and we looked
pretty good doing it all right
we have now reached the end of our
stream
actually which means it's finally time
to give away the coupon code to unlock
some in-game
collectibles and announce the big
news but first things first let's show
that coupon code really quick
and joe please explain to us what this
coupon code is going to give to our
viewers
all right that coupon code that you see
on the screen
that actually gives you 50 potential
reports
well potential reports actually it
strengthens you
on the base stats of your character so
i mean you'll be able to redeem this
code once the game is out in your region
don't worry about writing it down or
anywhere because we will remind you
to redeem the code and wear it too so
see you in the game when it launches
thank you so much joe and for all of our
viewers
make sure you jot that code down really
quick so that you can get your goodies
but that is you got it i don't believe
joe for a second i wrote it down i wrote
it down i'm not
trusting anybody to remind me about this
code it's over my slack right now
write it down i try to do my job right
[Laughter]
well if you're like me and you have
short-term memory you probably already
forgot it so write it down
all right everyone that's not all we
have to announce though we have some
huge news let's play the video join
my revolution
if you're like me you're fighting for
the future
a battle has just begun all about to
collide with each other
it's going to be the most dangerous
mission you've ever faced
let's get moving
pre-register now
there you go oh
there you go
there we go that's right
25 8 25
be ready it's so close enjoy your
superiority while it lasts canada
[Laughter]
august 25th is my time we'll be waiting
i've been dying to let the world know we
actually locked it locked this game down
for a while
so i mean the game has been ready we're
actually of course you know like putting
all the you know last minute efforts
together to make sure the game is ready
for the worldwide
whew can't believe we are already here
yes indeed already here a month away
marvel
future revolution will launch on august
25th globally and of course we cannot
wait
to play this game also don't forget to
pre-register you can pre-register
now at marvelfuturerevolution.com you
can get a
comics inspired in-game costume for a
hero of your choice and we also add
the coupon code from earlier to give you
even more awesome stuff
for your character i cannot believe
we have reached the end of our stream
already but we definitely
went over a ton of stuff today we talked
about the story
the open and vast universe we customized
our character
we hopped into multiplayer we checked
out skills we took down the bad guys
we did a lot and all of it is thanks to
marvel future evolution
for sponsoring our stream today don't
forget everyone pre-register
and get ready to play marvel future
revolution on august 24th
25th we will see you next time
peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you